royal watchers are counting down to
maybe Sussex rival nothing to report
just yet but if anybody has any details
that would beat Prince Harry's Big
Brother Prince William right
not exactly the uncle to me said this to
New Zealanders when asked if there was
Rory old baby update baby Sussex could
arrive any time yesterday
Harry attended the London Marathon and
did look nervous for an expectant papa
et has learned from a royal source that
in the fall area Megan planned to make
an official tour to Africa so will their
baby join mom and dad on the tour in
2014 Prince George turned nine months
old during an official trip to Australia
with William and Kate the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex could bring their baby
along to the continent Harry has called
his second home so what about those
reports Harry and Megan are considering
moving to Africa the palace calls plans
for the Duke and Duchess to relocate for
an official position speculative but our
source says a future short-term job in
Africa is accurate and that the details
will be formalized after the baby
arrives and happy Anniversary William
Kate it was eight years ago when they
tied the knot at Westminster Abbey three
kids later will never forget this
magical moment
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]